when we're talking about nutrients all  of these discussions should be framed in  terms of bioavailability how much of  that nutrient can you actually get out  of that plant let's just think about  spinach when you're eating spinach do  you think are you eating it because  you're like i'm getting a certain  mineral out of it or a vitamin or  something i'm eating it because  i do think that there are some some some  nutrients to it but i also think that  there's fiber in it so spinach is  actually a really interesting one  because spinach is very hot don't  oxalates knowledge is power you're  welcome no it's actually really high in  oxalate most kidney stones in the world  i think 80 percent are calcium oxalate  kidney stones where do we get oxalate we  get oxalate from things like almonds  spinach rhubarb beets beet greens very  high in oxalates so chocolate also is  pretty high in oxalates jen we need to  end this interview it's over